hello everyone and welcome to what
appears to be the most important game of
the Olympiad uh from the final round
it's Max farmer than representing the
Netherlands versus Jacob representing
team Uzbekistan who are of course having
a brilliant brilliant event and they're
fighting for first place and Netherlands
although there they've been fighting on
the sidelines for the entire Olympia now
they've done incredibly well and they
get the face Uzbekistan in the final
round and uh everything is uh hanging uh
well uh around this game uh board one
was abusator versus Anish giri that game
ended in a draw then yakuba versus
Jordan bomb Forest also in the dinner
draw and uh cindero versus Benjamin Bok
also ended in the draw so here it is all
up to Max farmer Dam and Jacob to see
who will grab that one extra point at uh
well either either get a really really
strong placement in the Olympic or even
win the Olympiad so let's see what
happened in this game max volume has the
white pieces and he opens with E4 we
have C5 again we are spoiled with with
games here just having a a sicilian game
not some sort of a Berlin uh we have
Knight to F3 Knight the C6 and here we
have Bishop to B5 fireman goes for the
range Medina rosolimo attack we have G6
and now castles we have Bishop to G7 uh
and pawn to C3 Knight to F6 attacking
the the for pawn and of course Pawn to
D4 now this is a very very well known
line uh you could go for Knight
characters and E4 then go then D5 comes
it's uh it's uh also very much played
but here avocado goes for C captures on
D4 we have E5 now uh challenging the the
Knight here this is also known as the
ludic of Gambit Knight to D5 and C
captures on D4 we have Knight to C7 now
attacking the bishop and not knife the
C3 and almost exclusively here uh
castles and Knight captures and B5 is
played but here we have A6 by makidov
and it is now as of move nine that we
have a completely new
so it's much much different
um sorry uh so it's much much different
than what you would usually have because
uh a white is expecting black to
eliminate the bishop of the board and
here you play A6 uh I don't know why the
interface does that now here you play A6
and you are allowing white to save the
bishop so here Bishop back to C4 and the
now a rocket of just castles with Bishop
to G5 now and here uh Bishop to G5
already uh black uh kind of equalizes uh
here the the main moves uh ought to be
Knight the E4 and Rook D1 and that's
kind of the surprise between the A6 move
if you don't notice if you try to play
actively then it could backfire so
Bishop to G5 makes sense as you wanna
put pressure on the black queen here now
comes the D6 and now black is putting a
whole lot of pressure on this E5 Pawn e
captures on D6 and now Queen characters
this is how uh avocado one pins and now
you don't have to worry about this
bishop here so upon the D5 attacks the
Knight Knights the A5 attacks the bishop
and queen to A4 now uh defending the
bishop this way sort of uh saying that I
know how to play this position but
without a light Square Bishop it makes
sense to to give it away Knight captures
Bishop Queen captures and pawn to B5 now
we have Queen to E4 and now of course
not going for Bishop to B7 the queen is
on e4 so we might as well grab a full
Tempo a bishop to F5 but not right away
uh before that we are going to play Rook
to E8 and defend our E7 Pawn uh so here
we have Rook 8 to D1 and only now Bishop
to F5 kicking away the queen queen to H4
uh and the now comes Pawn to B4
attacking the Knight here Knights the E4
and now Bishop captures an E4 we have
Queen characters on e4 uh and the queen
characters and B2 grabbing the pawn now
uh your hunger is up upon and you have
to play uh well just an incredibly
precise move uh in order to uh in order
to not be worse here it's not easy to
spot uh and in the game it was missed
here Rook fd1 was played the strongest
way to play this is Bishop to F4 it's uh
it's a very forcing line and it wins
back the pawn point is that now you are
attacking the queen here once the queen
moves doesn't really matter where we're
going to capture the Knight here and the
ones Queen captures on C7 is played uh
we play Queen captures on B4 attack the
bishop here and the ones we defend with
Rook to B8 then D6 so this is all very
very much forced uh e captures Queen
captures and now you decline a queen
trade you go for Queen A5 Queen to C4
and you get this position where it's
equal material but it's a bishop against
a knight on an open board material on
both sides of the board the black should
be a little bit better but nothing
serious so that's how you should play
this however after Rook after E1 he
allows a vacuum of this beautiful Bishop
to C3 move which keeps the pawn and now
it's just very hard to prove anything
here with white so Rook to E3 now comes
Pawn to F6 chases away the bishop and
the problem is if you play something
like Bishop to F4 you attack the queen
then E5 is incredibly strong and now you
cannot go captures Alpha song as The
Rook on D1 would be hanging so let's say
Bishop H6 now comes Knight to B5 and
okay it's a nice position white has a
pass Pawn on D5 but black has this
massive expansion here he has a
beautiful opponent B4 the bishop
controlling everything here and C3 so
it's very very hard to play this with
white uh chances are black would win
this very very quickly so instead uh
Varma tries Queen to H4 he tries
sacrificing a piece but of course
avocado doesn't accept if phone captures
Knight captures it looks uh like you're
allowing too much but still after H5
black should be okay but me okay it's
the final game of the Olympiad so much
is hanging in the balance here uh we
don't wanna over push our luck so here
Knight captures on D5 instead and now
Rook e to D3 putting pressure on the
Knight just Pawn to E6 with Bishop
captures and F6 uh Bishop captures and
F6 uh and now comes uh uh well instead
of this bishop captures an F6 you could
play Queen F4 Queen F4 is basically
enough to get a winning Advantage but
it's uh it's hard to visualize such
things now uh what are we playing here
the the bishop is attacked three times
so you have to play something in Bishop
G5 we just trade queens and now you have
a winning end game so that's one way to
do it but uh the the move that was
played in the game is just uh well it's
just a much more practical solution to
the idea uh Bishop captures and F6 Queen
captures an F6 and now the move from the
thumbnail Queen characters on H2 uh such
a such a classy move uh getting rid of
your your queen from D6 so the Knight
can move and capture the queen so King
captures an H2 Knight captures an F6 and
now you have this end game where black
is up to pawns but still two uh two
Rooks for each Knight for each side it's
not going to be easy to prove this Rook
the D6 goes after the pawn also prepares
to double up on the sixth rank with Rook
B6 something like Rook D6 uh Knight E4
attacks the rook and the df2 pawn here
so now just Rook to B6 and well you
could guard this with A5 and then kind
of force the whites to maybe defend with
King back to G1 maybe that would be okay
uh we have an instant trade Knight
captures an F2 uh and then now we have
Rook to D7 not going for this B4 Pawn uh
here he wants to uh he doesn't feel like
he has the chance to really bounce back
so he wants to double up on the seventh
Rank and go Knight to G Knight to G5 and
try to go for some sort of an attack
here uh so here Knight the G4 uh this is
the only way uh to survive this position
and to still fight for the win with
black you have to play this with Tempo
and then bring the Knight to F6 again
with Tempo to save your position King H3
Knight to F6 now attacks The Rook Rook D
back to D6 now puts pressure on the E6
spawn and on the A6 Pawn so A5 and now
not going for this capture right away
because even though you can win a pawn
here uh it's uh still just much much
better for black you're gonna play Rook
to B8 start pushing that B Pawn and you
will win the game very quickly so
Knights the G5 Max uh goes uh for
everything now he he's hoping to get
those Rooks up up to the seventh rank
Rook 8 to d8 we have to trade off a pair
of Rooks Rook captures Rook captures and
now finally Rook captures on E6 we have
Rook the D3 with check Pawn to G3 and
now Knight to H5 putting pressure on
that the G3 pawn and the situation on
the clock is uh very very tricky uh Max
has some six minutes on the clock uh
vocative has five minutes on the clock
and four more moves until they reach
time control so here King the H4 very
very classy idea uh just saying that if
you go for Rook captures or Knight
captures on G3 I will have a whole lot
of control play we can even show it for
example a rook captures on G3 rookie 8
check King G7 rookie 7 check King to F6
now Rook F7 check you can play King to
E5 it's not a problem and after Rook the
E7 check King to D6
uh so it's uh nothing to worry about you
don't have this this check because of
course the real Kings so you have to
play root captures on each seven the
game continues black still has the two
pawns here on the queen side and will be
winning uh but maybe it's too much to to
allow so instead Knight back to G7 no
point in rushing anything uh black so
just winning here so you might as well
take your time Rook the A6 now going
after the A5 pawn and now Knight to the
F5 with check winning the G3 Pawn King
G4 Rook counters and G3 King to F4 and
now Rook to E3 this is again a very very
classy move point is that if you go for
Rook to A3 it seems like you're
defending all of your pawns you're
winning this Pawn the problem is there's
a rook 8 checking G7 and Rook A7 check
and you lose this Pawn so you might be
giving uh away some counter play for no
reason and there are a couple of moves
that you absolutely have to play in
order to win this king of f8 is the one
must move play Knight captures on H7 now
King the E8 again the only winning move
of course King G8 and ends in the draw
Knight F6 tracking the d8 and now Rook
the D7 check King to C8 and now Rook D2
will defend the A2 Pawn like I said okay
the black position is still winning but
maybe it's a bit too much to to give so
Rook the E3 instead giving up the A5
Pawn Rook captures on A5 and now Rook
the E7 we have rooked a B5 going after
the B4 Pawn as well now comes H6
attacking the Knight here Rook the B8
check King to G7 and now Knight to F3
uh waiting with uh with the capture as
our Knight was hanging Knight to E3 and
now King to G3 so now it's it's only a
matter of technique but there's so much
hanging on this game that it can be uh
you know it it's such an intense moment
uh it's hard to imagine how how it even
was done you have to try and push this
for a win uh Rook to E4 now comes Rook
B7 check of course Max will try not to
you know just harass the black king hope
for something King to F6 will Rook the
B6 with check King Tab 7 Rook the B7
check and King to E8 with Knight to D2
and now Rook to D4 attacks the Knight
Knight B3 attacks The Rook now comes
Knight to F5 with the check King to F3
and now Rook the C4 now we're gonna
further harass the white king and start
pushing those pawns so Knight to D2
attacks The Rook Rook to D4 we have
Knights the E4 and now Pawn to G5 we
have Knight to C5 and the pawn to G4
with check King the E2 and now Pawn to
G3 so now the pawns are incredibly
dangerous King to F3 rooked the C4
attacks the knight in 96 and now rooked
the C3 again with check King F4 attacks
the Knight but now just Pawn to G2 you
don't care about your knight because you
are getting a queen into the game and uh
it seems like maybe there could be
something here uh because you are so
close with the King but not really if
your king was here that would be a whole
different story then maybe you would
have some uh you know rooked G8 ideas
but your king is not here so instead
after G2 we have knighted the G7 check
hoping for Knight captures real captures
and then the Rook regards the queening
square but here just King to d8 and now
there really isn't all that much you can
do here Max tries one last trick in the
position he goes for Rook to B8 with
check but now just King to D7 and it was
in this position unmove 60 that max
volume atom resigned to the game and as
we know that the other games from the
match ended in a draw this is basically
the game that won team Uzbekistan the uh
VHS Olympiad 2022. so big
congratulations to team Uzbekistan I
posted a nice photo on Twitter of the
winning team but you have so many so
many of them that you are welcome to
check them out chess 24 also posted a
very nice photo
uh so uh do do check it out uh here the
one last trick in the position that I
was mentioning after this is that if
somehow King the E7 is played and you
might play it I mean you're completely
winning you know you might okay make one
more move uh crazier things have
happened I mean we've seen the the
Shanklin Rook lift that's that's the
thing now uh the point is that now
Knight captures on F5 comes with check
and you cannot win this anymore if you
go King F7 to prevent Rook to G8 now we
just go Rook B7 check we continue
harassing the black king king of fade
Rook to B8 check and if you go of course
here then we go after uh the past Pawn
uh so that would be the idea but of
course uh he's not to be tricked King to
D7 was played now there are no more
checks and of course now you just resign
there's no more uh playing this once you
play any move or you can give one check
then we just move the king and once you
move the Rook we bring a Queen into the
game and that's it so brilliant
brilliant game by by jacking the rocket
of taking down Max verbandam with the
black pieces in the round of the
Olympiad and thus winning the gold medal
for team Uzbekistan truly truly
incredible uh so yeah that's the game I
hope you guys enjoyed it if you have any
other of your own favorite games uh do
share and I will try to cover them there
were a couple of very nice games in in
the final round uh so do use hashtag
suggestion as usual I would like to
thank Michael Colbert Sunil chandrakant
madrakar chess connects us kissing and
Kathleen Althea Cashman for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon at continuing the coverage of
the Olympiad of some of the other games
and then we are going to to Miami as you
guys might have expected uh so yeah
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your game of
your day